can we talk about the six types of
audience roles okay the first one is a
visitor
yeah the visitor is when you what you
think of when you have an art gallery or
a museum
um where the visitor comes in and they
enjoy
um and appreciate works of art or
objects or um you know they come to
learn they come to
appreciate a place but they don't play a
role in the story of The Experience they
are visitors to the place where the
environment the story world is not
affected by their presence so this is
the most common uh type of experience
where people will go to a you know
everything from a playground to a museum
they're visiting a place and they don't
have an active role to play in the
experience this is passive yes okay and
then number two is The Spectator that
also sounds passive yeah a spectator
um has is a more passive a participant
as well you could think of like sporting
events or concerts but there's a little
bit of participation in that they can
respond to the performer or to the
athlete that you know they can clap they
can scream they can shout their support
all of them or boo right so there's a
little bit more participation but it's
it's still somewhat passive it's not as
uh
um
participatory as other forms of visitors
number three is participant hyphen
immersive
when you think about uh some of the
immersive experiences out there
um where they have projection mapping
around a space and the
um the the
environment reacts
towards the participant that goes into
this immersive space maybe you touch
something and you know there's like fish
in a digital fish in an aquarium let's
say and if you touch you can feed the
fish by like you know touching on the
wall or something like that so there is
a form of participation that requires
you to engage with the immersive
environment around you it doesn't change
the story in a drastic way but it
responds to you as you touch or
um perhaps whatever kind of action that
you do to create something that may have
uh
um a small consequence but nothing that
is going to change the outcome of the
entire experience or the story it's a
light touch light touch participation
participant Interactive
so a participant interactive is um
a little more engaging
perhaps it's a crank that you have to
turn in order for this invention or this
machine to work maybe it's some buttons
that you have to push maybe it's uh you
know handles that you have to pull and
look through and discover so there's a
sense that it is interactive that you
are required to take some action in
order to fully experience uh the story
and the world and it's a great way for
kids to explore the world around them so
I love seeing museums and places where
kids can just touch everything and
interact with things so that they can
learn about it science museums is a
really great example of that and uh just
really engaging
actively participatory type of
activities
where you can really see uh you know
results and consequences answers to your
to your actions
number five hero
so hero is one in which
if you go through this experience and
the story world the characters the
experiences around you
uh have a direct consequence to your
actions so if you are going to meet with
a character in a town let's say in this
world whatever you say or do with this
particular
character is going to have very big
consequences to the world so this is
really the most extreme form of
immersive storytelling how can you as a
Creator put your visitor into a hero
role where they can change the
consequences of the story and the world
and again I go back to video games you
know gaming uh where you truly have this
opportunity to change the um you know
the true Choose Your Own Adventure type
of format where you can change the
outcome of your story and other
characters outcomes as well is the most
extreme form of immersion of
Storytelling that you can do and
I think we have yet to really see
an experience where they it fully does
that where you can truly create an
outcome that is personal extremely
personal to you it's difficult and
challenging because you have you know
Mass groups of people visitors audiences
coming to a place so how can you create
a story that's tailored only to you and
personalized only to you when you're in
this setting with crowds of people and
so there are different ways that you can
do it there's some that makes it a truly
personal experience or just you and one
other person if you think about like
some of the experiences out there in the
world when you're traveling let's say
and you have a private guide who takes
you to through a safari or whatever it
is right there's there's varying ways
for you to be the hero of that story in
that Journey
but it's it's still one that we're we've
touched the surface of an immersive
storytelling and I think we have a long
way to go to really create something
that is truly
um that truly makes you feel like you
are the hero of the story and I'm really
excited to see where it can take us
and then Creator last but not least this
is one that I think gosh you know when I
think about
wear immersive storytelling can go
and how I'm seeing the trends of what
you know my kid and the younger
Generations are doing in their own free
time things like Roblox and Minecraft
and fortnite where and you know being
YouTubers
there is a desire to create and express
yourself in uh your own way
how do we create an immersive
storytelling experience or world where
we can embrace you as a Creator and this
is perhaps
touching on you know the metaverse or
touching on something that you know AR
or something that is more virtual
but is there a world where there is a
combination of like the physical the
digital the virtual where it feels like
perhaps There's No Boundaries anymore
right and it for a lot of people that
can be really scary to think about you
know what's real and what's not
um but when I see
what's what's emerging in this world and
how we all want to have that sense of
ownership and a sense of creation I
think that this is really going to be
what's going to be very exciting in this
particular format of immersive
storytelling how can you
create a world that is specific to you
and have visitors perhaps come to your
world experience the story that you set
up we see that in TV and movies and
video games
maybe we can see that in the physical
world maybe we can see that in a way
that is scalable uh you know that other
people from some other part of the world
can come and experience the world that
you've created and how do you create
something you know invite others to come
and co-create with you how do you create
environments that change with time that
evolve over time that perhaps does it
organically I know that it's something
that um I'm very excited to see because
it really pushes
how we think about how we perceive the
world and what is you know all my life
since I was a child I think there's
always been you know multiple worlds
that I live in in my head
and imagine if there is going to be a
landscape
where you can go in and out of those
worlds as you please that it doesn't
just live in your head
that it can be uh
manifested into something that other
people can see and share
and that you can continually change and
evolve into uh an ecosystem that other
people can come in and collaborate as
well and again we're seeing it in video
games we're seeing in all this but how
do we how can we bring that into the
physical world